when I was a college student I was
interested in the issue of world hunger
and I wanted to do something big about
it we used to do these tiny little
fundraisers for Oxfam and my senior year
I decided to organize a bike ride across
America and 39 of us rode 4,200 miles
across the country to raise money for
Oxfam it's a very powerful experience
and then in the early 90s I began to
lose many friends like many others to
AIDS and there was nothing big that the
average person could do you could buy a
red ribbon or you could go to a
black-tie you know chicken dinner but it
didn't equate with the level of grief
that you had or the passion you had to
do something so I started a company
for-profit company called pelota team
works and we invented these very unique
charitable events called the AIDS rides
and then the breast cancer three days
and what was unique about them was they
didn't last a morning or a day they
lasted seven days or three days and you
had to bicycle 600 miles or walk 60
miles over the course of seven days or
three days and sleep in a tent in this
massive mobile city that we created and
you had to raise a minimum of four
figures for the privilege so for the
AIDS ride you had to raise at least
$2,000 and we were very successful we
tapped into a deep hunger on the part of
people who had AIDS or had breast cancer
or who'd lost someone to one of those
issues to do something heroic so over
the course of nine years we had 180
2,000 people participate in one of these
events and they raised 556 million
dollars which was more money raised more
quickly for those two causes than any
private event operation in history I'm
Dan pelada the book is entitled
uncharitable it's from Tufts University
Press and the book comes from ten years
of producing these events which gave me
access to a very
make window into the way the public
thinks about charity the questions it
asks before it makes donations the
restraints that it places on charity and
I began to see a whole picture coalesce
that was very dysfunctional well we have
to rule books we have one for charity
and one for the rest of the economic
world and that separate rulebook
discriminates against charity in five
areas first in compensation you know we
have a visceral reaction to people
making very much money in charity which
means charity can't pay competitive
wages based on value gives our young
people a horrible you to be exclusive
choice between doing well and doing good
and sends very talented people right out
of business school directly into the
for-profit sector because they can't
afford the kind of annual pay cut the
nonprofit ethic requires the second area
is advertising marketing you know we let
the for-profit sector spend until the
last dollar no longer produces a penny
of value so lots of freedom to advertise
which is why we're pummeled with ads for
Botox and Budweiser and iPods but we
don't want to see our donations spent on
paid advertising in charity so charity
can't build demand for its product which
is these different causes third area is
risk you know we let Paramount Studios
make 100 million dollar movie that flops
and we consider it part of their
business model and a search for the big
successes but we don't I can tell you
from personal experience if you produce
a five million dollar charity event that
doesn't produce a seventy-five percent
return in year one you know call the
Attorney General so charities are
petrified of trying bold new revenue
generating ideas and it can't develop
the kind of learning curves the
for-profit sector can fourth is
long-term investment in revenue
development you know Amazon went for
what six years without paying a return
to investors in the interest of a longer
term objective building market dominance
well if we ever tried some charitable
endeavor they didn't return money to
Nene for six years you know there'd be a
crucifixion and the fifth and final area
is profit itself the for-profit sector
can use profit as an incentive to
attract capital the nonprofit sector by
definition cannot so it has the donation
as its only financial instrument which
means the for-profit sector monopolizes
the multi trillion-dollar capital
markets so if you put these five things
together and no competitive compensation
no meaningful advertising no ability to
take risk the way the for-profit sector
can no ability to invest in the long
term and no capital markets you've just
put charity at the most extreme
disadvantage to the for-profit sector
and then you know we call this charity
and charity could not be undermined with
more reverence paid to charity but
people miss something very big which is
the market for altruism and you know we
have as we have a visceral need to help
one another
you know we enjoy helping one another
that's not selfless it's very good for
the self you know it I feel very good
when I do something for someone who's
who's hurting well that's a taste that's
as big if not bigger than our taste for
music our taste for art our taste for
leisure and we ought to start to
capitalize on it by using capitalism by
using markets and it's a it's a way that
the market can redistribute income
because the market will want to do
redistribute income because it will be
better educated about these causes and
and will tap into people's natural
desire to help one another rather than
forcing redistributions of income so I
think we've missed a huge opportunity
with all of this moral regulation that's
on that's on charity the ideological
roots are fascinating to read about the
Puritans you know the original settlers
to New England in the 1630s and they
came here to for religious reasons but
they also it's very clear came here
because they knew they could make a lot
of money here and they were aggressive
capitalists they established the
Massachusetts Bay Colony as a
corporation but they were also
Calvinists and Calvin taught that they
were to hate themselves they were
despicable in the eyes of God and that
self-interest was a sure path to eternal
damnation well this you know created a
real problem for them here they're all
self-interested in profit minded and
their religion is telling them profit is
horrible so charity became this kind of
economic sanctuary this compartment
where they could do penance for their
profit-making tendency so it necessarily
had to have a different set of rules how
could you make money in charity if
charity was your penance for making
money so they created these two worlds
where there was only ever one and the
merchants and the farmers and the
builders of the world got free market
capitalism and the Nene got this
nonprofit ethic this Dogma whereby
everything that worked in the market was
banished and you can see that we still
live with this irrational system today
like you know you can't make money
investing in a soup kitchen but
Campbell's can make a profit investing
in the charity is selling the charity
their soup so you have all these
internal inconsistencies which point out
some huge irrationality at work I think
eventually what we need is a change in
the tax code to allow nonprofit
organizations without tax exemption to
accept investments on which they can pay
a financial return as a means of
generating more capital the nonprofit
sector is tiny compared to government
the for-profit sector is fairly massive
compared to government I think if we let
the nonprofit sector play by the same
rules it could be the custodian of many
of these problems that we're now
assigning to government simply because
government's big the only reason
government's big is is because we make
it big and and the nonprofit sector
could be huge if we gave it more free